tens of thousands of people left Wuhan
China this morning for the first time in
two-and-a-half months
China's government just lifted travel
restrictions on the city where the
worldwide coronavirus outbreak began
rainy Inocencio shows us a region
possibly on the rebound at the stroke of
midnight luhan celebrated liberation
from its 76th day lockdown honoring its
frontline workers in a light show
drivers sped off as highways reopened
and high-speed trains departed just
after dawn along city streets cherry
trees are now blossoming as shoppers
returned to reopen stores a stark
contrast to a city that just days ago
was under one of the largest lock downs
in history CBS News was the first US
News Network to report from Wuhan in
January our team evacuated just before
the city went into confinement a measure
that grew to more than 60 million people
across China emergency hospitals sprung
up almost overnight and empty streets
were the new normal those who disobeyed
containment were beaten hauled away or
sealed in their homes by authorities 21
year old megan monroe has been in Wuhan
since the lockdown began everyone's like
out and about and everyone was just so
so happy I felt joy in the area but
epidemiologists like Ben cowling warned
that widespread travel out of Wuhan
could mark the start of China's second
wave one of my concerns is that we're
gonna get into a nasty cycle of having
to have repeated lock downs maybe every
two or three months because there'll be
a resurgence in infections for CBS this
morning
Ramey innocencio Tokyo Japan